كمتطوعة في مؤسسة أسد البحر النيوزيلندية ،
تراقب هانا سنويًا
أسود البحر حيث تعيش بالقرب من
شبه جزيرة أوتاغو في الجزيرة الجنوبية للبلاد
[موسيقى] ،
إنها نوع من مجالسة الأطفال التي تعرفها
خاصة
عندما تكون حاملاً أو لديها صغار.
نوع من
التأكد من أن شخصًا ما على الأقل قد
رآهم جميعًا يقومون بفحصهم خلال
النهار ، حيث
يوجد امتداد ضعيف ،
فهذه الجراء جزء من جيل جديد
من أسود البحر التي عادت إلى هذا
الساحل بعد غياب طويل تم
طردهم من البر الرئيسي.  قبل قرن من
الزمان عن طريق صيد أسود البحر النيوزيلندية
نجت في جزر شبه القارة القطبية الجنوبية
حتى يوم واحد في عام 1993
كان لدى أنثى من جزر أوكلاند
حديقة هنا في البر الرئيسي
وشرعت في الحصول على 11 جروًا ، لذا كانت
هذه الأنثى مسؤولة عن
إعادة  مجموعة من أسود البحر
إلى أوتاغو
التي سميت أسد البحر المحوري
أمي تركتها وراءها سلالة من أسود البحر
التي لا تزال تزدهر على هذا الساحل
اليوم
ولكنها لا تكتفي بذلك.  التزم بهذا
الخط الساحلي ،
فهم يدفعون حقًا إلى الداخل بقدر ما يمكنهم
، وهذا عادة ما يضعهم في مواجهة
طريق
تهتم به حول تلك الطرق
، وبالتالي فإن أحد أكبر
التهديدات في الواقع هو بعض طرق
النقل
تلك التي عادت أسود البحر إليها.
خط ساحلي مختلف تمامًا عن الخط الساحلي الذي تركوه
منذ أكثر من مائة عام ،
حيث يوجد شواطئ مزدحمة
تحافظ على سلامتهم ، وهي مهمة
حارس التنوع البيولوجي جيم فايف ،
يحب البشر الذهاب إلى الشاطئ في الصيف
تحب أسود البحر التكاثر على الشواطئ
في الصيف
[موسيقى]
أسود البحر الصغيرة فضولي
وممتع حقًا ،
فهم يعلمون أن راكبي الأمواج
هناك يستمتعون أيضًا ، لذا فهم يريدون
الانضمام إليهم ، كما تعلمون ، الحيوانات الاجتماعية
نصيحتنا هي أنك لا
تتفاعل معهم ، فقط تجاهلهم و
تابع ما تفعله
[موسيقى] ،
مرحبًا
على الرغم من تعافيها هنا
، تعد أسود البحر النيوزيلندية واحدة من أندر
أنواع أسد البحر في العالم التي تواجه تهديدات من
الأمراض والصيد العرضي في مصايد الأسماك المحلية
هذا يجعل حماية هذا العدد المتزايد من
السكان أكثر أهمية
، وهذا هو المكان الذي يأتي فيه السكان المحليون في
المجتمعات عادة بمجرد أن يبدأوا في
التعرف عليهم
، فإنهم يهتمون حقًا بحماية
أسود البحر التي تتكاثر في
الحصانات التي تضغط عليها من خلال
يأتي
الناس  فوجئوا فقط بالعثور على
هذه الحيوانات في الفناء الخلفي لمنزلهم
[موسيقى]
هذا العام ولد 21 جروًا من أسد البحر
في شبه جزيرة أوتاغو
، وهو أعلى رقم منذ
عودتهم إلى هذه الشواطئ وسيبقي
جليسات أسد البحر مشغولة بلا اكتراث
لسنوات قادمة
إنه أمر رائع جدًا
لأنك ستتمكن من رؤيتهم
بوجوه مرة أخرى
بمجرد التعرف عليهم أن أسود البحر
لديهم شخصيات ، كل ما في الأمر أن رؤيتهم
يستمتعون بها مع احترام
مساحتهم بالطبع
هذا هو الشيء الذي أستمتع به كثيرًا
[موسيقى]